So it turns out that this first combination of coefficients for x 6 and 1 does
not work, this is the wrong one we can only know that though by trying out these
different numbers, now if we could have put a negative one here and the negative
one here that our middle term would have become 6x trans negative 1 or negative
6x minus x which is negative 7x But unfortunately, -1 times -1 does not equal
-5. We could do that same exact process for each of the 4 numbers in this slot
figuring out what they would need to be over here to come up with -7 to
eventually rule out all of the possibilities up here. Going with the same
process down here, for the factors that have 3x and 2x in them, shows us that we
need a -5 here and a 1 here .So that to get our middle term, we have 3x times 1
minus 10x, or negative 7x. Negative 5 times 1 is negative 5. So this is what
works.